you
you
good morning Millennials
I'm just really thinking about Luke um
now who you're just talking about it's
one that has like the same big dick
energy I totally had they together
you're right I'm Elena's hub if I was a
man home the biggest penis
Wow that is no you would have massive
balls yeah yeah yeah like saggy ones
oh my god when I was when I was in
Europe I went to the beach it wasn't
even a nude beach but all beaches are
nude what did you see and jagged they
take any pictures how mean is that oh my
god like I well I was so confused about
the protocol there but anyways there
were so many new people and it wasn't
even like a tourist like some people
were nude some people were and it wasn't
a big deal it's not like I sought out a
nude beach we like landed on a beach and
I was like titties but what was super
tape I did not partake but like the
titties were actually like fine like it
wasn't a big cheese and in Miami you can
see titties sometimes because a lot of
people from South America live there and
they are like cool with their titties
and I've seen boobs me and Ben resetting
at the addition and literally the most
gorgeous girl like she should have been
a porn star it was laying and make it at
the beach and me event couldn't stop
staring at her well so many of the women
like who wear topless I really didn't
have like much going on upstairs so we
didn't feel so silly Asians but if we
could do that right there were a few
pairs that were like okay brave Zumba's
but then there were also some men nude
like no bottoms and it was crazy like
one guy bushes
I didn't like no but I was walking down
the beach so crazy and like one guy was
just like laying and like his it was
just where his legs spread or don't put
together and flat but I could see like
you could see everything and then one
guy was leaning up against the wall
charging his phone sitting in a W with
his legs up with the chart ever good so
his slug ballsack with like touching
ground more than that the charger was
running up his clothes like it looks
like his ball sack was charging his
phone it was it was insane I was
wondering I took a picture like a normal
guy you coming that story but I didn't
know that he was sitting in a W I
thought he had one knee up against both
knees up directly sitting on the floor
sitting on the floor scaling with one
like oh my god that isn't [ __ ] it was
terrible why I was like if I took a
picture in like that was in the
background or something like am I not
allowed to post it for his privacy
like I know Instagram would probably
take it down but like maybe I could get
it on I don't know because it's like a
part of the background like the fabric
of the equation and it's like you're
clearly comfortable
well they care Lessig evern America is
still like wound up about privacy
whereas europeans it's like we don't
give a [ __ ] like when I run that Carl
got in trouble for keeping the idea if
the identities of those people on the
plane anonymous since she still got in
trouble oh that's true that was crazy
like everyone like no one cares right so
for that reason not that interesting
thank you I didn't take any pictures
yeah but no I just meant like for our
chat like not for my name I didn't have
my phone with me like I'm fake I know
but I it's imprinted in my mind for life
so jealous that's the sort of thing that
you can't forget well no matter how hard
you try at dinner last night have you
ever heard of the disease elephantitis
of the nuts
I've heard of elephantitis so I can only
imagine of the knife remember that movie
Elephant Man that we watching when
you're kids I couldn't leave if I cried
for like a week you know what's so weird
I was talking about that movie on the
track we're gonna try Oh cuz we were at
like some sort of like circus thing and
I was talking about how the circus is
kind of like outdated you know we have
so much entertainment now like we don't
need to like look at people who just
look weird in order to laugh no or we
also don't need to abuse animals to
laugh right and that had like even
though I love Petey bar and I'm like the
circus has run its course like yeah if
you were alive in 2018 he wouldn't be
exploited yeah he'd know he would be
doing something else cuz he's a showman
yeah anyways and then I was talking
about the Elephant Man and how it really
stuck with me and I realize like we were
way too young to see that movie and
especially because we never watched any
crazy movies growing up like no I didn't
see all of Titanic until last year no me
neither
honestly the only movie the only things
that we watched were that were like
somewhat dark word - grassy and when a
girl got raped we weren't allowed to
watch it anymore in the show and also we
saw Schindler's List because like we had
to be well-rounded um members of the
community and that would be really
[ __ ] with me you never from the movies
like they're always movies about like
sad [ __ ] but there are movies that stay
with you totally you want to know mine
I'd meet you okay wait let me just not
forget the Elephant Man meteo paper
clips that documentary about the
Holocaust idea and the pursuit of
happiness with Will Smith when he gives
the five dollars to the guy like that is
the that is the worst like that movie
sucked me okay here mine ready Elephant
Man obviously Schindler's List
we [ __ ] I should have went first because
of my dementia ha
[ __ ] and I had such good ones you need
to give me like five minutes although ok
ok oh this one like for some reason
United 93 I love it cried into a towel
in our bathroom in our house after I
watch it if anyone anyone to see I've
literally couldn't stop crying it's the
saddest maybe ever and like that guy
that actor um who I love Will Arnett he
was so good in it and like now he's my
favorite actor just because he did the
movie and I hope we did it for free and
I hope that will be was successful it's
literally just the most heartless right
um so if you were like I watched black
oh and but like later in life if you
watch that now like if we watch that
younger it's so [ __ ] up 12 years of
slave but also again I watch that as an
adult so like I had more of an emotional
like control on myself no oh my god that
would be really bothered me like to know
level cuz like obviously slavery's
horrible disgusting but he was free oh
my god that and he just thought those
guys wanted to like let him play violin
in their band oh my god that movie it's
horrible and I didn't want you when it
was like Oscar season and it was getting
so much hype and I was like okay well I
should watch it oh my god
Solomon that was his name Solomon that
was the worst movie I ever saw ever in
my life he could not get off the
plantation and then one day his papers
arrives it is the worst I started to
spoil the movie for you the way for 12
years 12 years oh and when he leaves
it's like bittersweet because like
there's literally 50 people still
enslaved on the front so he's least
accepted back to his family be like him
at everyone else yeah and they're like
happy for him but like not really it's
[ __ ] terrible movie yeah whoa Brad
Pitt was so mean oh my god oh my god I'm
remembering more and the guy with the
letter oh my god he brought this letter
I wasn't a little mean oh he was he the
good guy he was decent okay oh oh my god
that's actually a horrible movie come
talk with me yeah this is like a not a
fun way to start off the show ah but
have better movies to talk about because
I finally watched a preppy connection
could transition and to all the boys I
loved before
okay let's search all the boys a little
before because I'm just like so jazzed
about it okay initial thoughts it was so
cute and so sweet and like I I feel like
there's a but coming
no no there's there's really not like I
also I was watching it because it felt
like it was like my homework
I just wish I had a more like
stress-free experience why aren't you
watching it now that there's all this
hype Peter well I didn't know it even
though there was this hyper on theater I
didn't know who she was really meant to
be with that kid I liked and that guy
Jake is that his name nice Josh Josh
like such a wiener I such a wiener like
oh my god and when they were in the
forest the field in the beginning I'm
like he's not even hot right I'm like
this can't be Peter Kaminski that
everyone's talking about
no oh no and then when like when Peter
came into the picture and I still wasn't
sure I just like that I didn't know
where the movie was going and then like
it was so and I feel like in those tapes
and movies it's always like the girl
gets attached and the guy doesn't and he
goes back to Jen and then he realizes
like no he liked her and she was like
now you don't get a yogurt from across
town like oh that yeah I really really
liked it that girl Arjun is so cute her
jaw was so cute and when he said the
thing about like Jen being pretty but
you have way better style I was like yes
she does like with her first day of
school or go watch you yesterday we were
like is he calling her ugly in that no
no cuz it she's pretty but you at least
know I don't I don't think so I think he
was trying to compliment Jen while he
also insulting her which cuz he's a nice
guy he respects women right he's not
just gonna [ __ ] all over her style and
her wearing Uggs was just like hilarious
that girl who plays her cousin is an
amazing actress what is she from she
looks so familiar I have no idea but
every scene she was in I thought she was
such a talented actress when she goes I
like your was like she was just such
like like I got every message she was
trying to convey but also it was weird
she didn't annoyed me a little bit not
gonna it was weird that like she really
lied to like her best best friend like I
thought that was me or to her little
sister like what's wrong with you it's
like embarrassing yeah but like weird
right how can you just lie so easily
take the people that you actually love
good uh Netflix one more time for being
in tune with what's necessary and like
casting someone who's like
internet-famous king batch I thought he
was so funny because it's an awesomeness
yeah and they're like a digital yeah but
they were like oh but he was like oh gee
like I'm so glad they addressed the fact
that her [ __ ] name was Laura Jean
like why did you have two names I don't
know it was confused that's her name in
the book and like they repeated her name
so many times in the movie so
by the end like I knew her name but if
they hadn't like I would have forgotten
what her name was
yeah except um Peter called her cubby
yeah or a large you know who I really
hated though her older sister hate it
hate it like she couldn't have gone to
college that's enough had she came home
too early no and like she was just I
didn't I didn't get in the first few
moments that like they had a special
relationship like I thought it was
always contentious and like what is she
doing dating a younger man that's her
sister's best friend like I couldn't
agree more that's [ __ ] up and then
that she made him boring by only wanting
to drink water nappy totally and wait me
and Margot that's why I say to Margot
last night like the first two minutes of
the movie really make it seem like it's
gonna be a very different movie like it
looks like it like a weird quirky like
art film and then it obviously gets
better but I thought the first scene is
very bizarre and wait when did you dozen
women three sisters are always together
like I really cringe every single time
like the sister dynamic wasn't working
for me except the little sister and the
middle sister in the middle I see Ramona
was like coming in after she was their
mom and I thought - she was like go set
the table girl yeah totally oh she is
the mom way they talk about like their
dead mom it's just like kids with
deceased parents do not talk like that
and honestly like Netflix stop killing
people's parents it's like you can have
a good rom-com without someone's mom
dying the kissing booth like full house
like it's hot bar that was killing off
the bomb because it's like you can't be
like a dynamic interesting person having
experienced loss and you know what
that's true I kind of see your point but
that scene in Peter's house well first
of all the now ray she looks like a
little traumatic because when Kitty met
Peter and then the next scene large he
goes to his house for dinner
she says over the narrations you think I
wish we didn't bring our families act as
if it was like Hiroshima
like for LA no as it's like that's what
became the demise of it right
nothing bad ever happened also as if it
didn't work out yeah like or that the
brother like was scarred or something
that little sister that was just like so
dramatic I'm necessary that scene I love
she's like sitting up and they're just
you're a good listener like I just am
obsessed with Laura Jean and by the way
she's gorgeous and there were like so
many scenes you know when it's she's so
interesting looking she
really looks different in a lot of the
scenes and she looked absolutely
stunning gorgeous when they went to that
party and he made her keep her hair down
oh man is a diner like that was the best
she ever looked well because she took
her hair down for the first time and
then like then you you realize like she
wore her hair down all the time because
like he liked her with her hair down and
that's Sealand she's on the bleachers
with Josh but the P thing and her hair
is in those two ponytails looks so
[ __ ] cute and qui like I am obsessed
with her ya know she's really like a
chameleon
she has great sash and she's such a cute
body she's the cutest and she could wear
anything and I just I really enjoyed
that
okay that's usually an overlooked piece
of movies it's like what Jojo he hangs
her joking's hair Joey thinks outfit she
was like always in a bathing suit and
like a wet so she shorts yeah she was
wearing what you wear to camp toes that
was really weird
no I agree and wait the best thing the
best part of it all wait wait best part
of it all John Corbett oh my god the man
of my dreams I love him so much I can be
like a gynecologist and I just know I
love that Netflix movies they said they
don't give me a pit it's like everyone
is financially savvy like they're there
it's like I thought one we went to
Peter's house and like his dad left it
would be like a broken home it has a
Jeep Wrangler right so like crazy and
like even Laura Jean chosen want to try
but like she has a nice Subaru the dad
is a Jaguar right old-school but still
like there's no pits like in Netflix
everyone is financially stable I know
that's not really what it's like in high
school but I don't care like I don't I
don't need to watch TV for other
people's financial struggles I live in
ya know also i when you said that you
watched kissing lieutenants trash after
watching this like this is one thing
that this movie did really well it's
like there were so many moments where
like you understood how and why they
were falling in love like there's so
many deep conversations that were had
whereas like in the kissing booth it's
just that watch montage totally I've
been making out all over town totally to
believe that now they're in love
know watching the kissing booth is like
oh I open experience except for the fact
that like the only reason why you really
believe that they're in love is because
these two people themselves are dating
in there yes you should now watch to all
the boys I love before like a couple
more times not as homework I'm now
watching probably like six times
and what's the actress's name Larkin and
or on Lana candor
yeah did she have a lot of she's got
three million and Noah Centennial's at
six million and he had a dick pic did
anyone see it me and Margaret
I did what are we working with ladies
I'm working with with it's Dyson BD he's
got some BD period where did you find
this
well I'm mark-to-market Gigi yeah
Margaux sent it to me and it also is all
over the toasters
yes of course it was anytime I saw Peter
Kaminsky also I was thinking in the
movie I'm like why do I keep thinking
his name's Noah and I guess cuz his name
is now oh by the way and everyone's
claiming to have originated this
particular call but like I originated at
first and I even looked it up to see if
he was Mark Ruffalo's son because not
only do they look so similar they talk
the same out of the side of their mouth
like her large chain there and they have
this weird like like not a list but I
got like a whistle in there I thought
that he was actually Mark Ruffalo son I
made the call first
is he no oh also I made an amazing call
this morning to snitch cuz the little
sister was you're not gonna get this but
the little sisters reminding me of
someone so much in the movie and I
couldn't figure it out and I didn't
really try to and as I'm talking to sit
I'm like doesn't she remind you haven't
it clicked
Drizzy from descendants too and they
look nothing alike in the movies and
Mark I was like is it possible they're
the same person and they are wait even
worse Jen is Mitch from River tonight
now what a chameleon she looks so
different I know it's the eggs it's the
maid she would never have worn out she's
like way too cool I'm Lucas and writer
Ross would have never put her never the
Lucas the one who got the letter who
turned out to be a being like her best
friend and like him such a good
supportive friend at the party when she
was like don't tell anyone I thought he
was totally gonna end up being like
sleuthy and tell Jen the whole thing he
was such a good friend know and he was
one who made her see the light and go to
the hot tub which the movies amazing I
have so many problems with with the hot
tub scene why that she's not wearing a
meeting so good there were so many I
like things that made me so mad ready
pack a bathing suit okay like that was
stupid and if you're gonna wear a Nike
I'm there packing this like it's a
school trip after all and by the way
people have been on it for years like
they would have said there's a honey you
packed a nightgown which is like very
thoughtful yeah you might have thought
of a ting so you know and she's very
thoughtful so not only did she would not
have a busier she wore a nightgown that
was granny though horrible so like just
put on a bathing suit like she's cute
and has a great body like I wanted to
see large and a [ __ ] big sue first of
all second of all when she finally gets
it and he's like you're coming in and
you're like yeah and she says I didn't
bring a bathing suit
but there's something in me there's
something wrong with her mouth and
something because she sounds um
she's signing she's like she's not
talking she's like I mean like it's so
weird
maybe they when they watch the movie
they realize they need an excuse as to
why she was in a nightgown and they like
dub did it maybe because you have a look
I didn't hear what she said everyone's
it like a hundred times the first time
it's just the scene is so important and
they like miss the mark on so many
things and it kept making me so angry
when he was like I even got you those
little yogurts that you like but the
cream markets all the way across town so
if I went all the way across town what
does that mean you must really like
yogurt like come on Laura Jean is
serious no but it all works out and then
what was really confusing is them
calling it a sex tape whatever they're
really just making out was so confused
cuz I like did she have sex just like
she go from like never having never been
kissed
really to losing your virginity which is
like do you but that's my like how
things have totally change what's the
term tables have turned
no it's like whatever brains not working
today yeah me neither brain can but it
was so wonderfully a dud oh wait and
then also the scene on the lacrosse
field like two important scenes like I
just I feel like they missed the mark a
little bit now it's just like when I
watched it I loved it but now that I'm
like analyzing it and like a little
critical would she made him turn around
and then like turn back around oh that
was my my meat but for all of that to
say I like you she should have said I
love you and then he said I love you and
she never said it back okay but like
she's large in know but like that would
have been brave not I like cuz you love
him
totally and it's called to all the boys
I ever loved no the boys I ever liked a
lot to other words I've loved before
whatever it's called it's a long I use
the word love yeah they have like
700,000 followers on Instagram just for
the movie they're going to make a sequel
they're both like alluding to it on
kissing booth it's like what would the
sequel be this would be better because
they're still in school but like those
junior it's like Jacob is across the
country like she has a motorcycle like
it's gonna the only way to make the
movie interesting is like if there's
problems in their relationship and you
know what I don't want to watch I know
what the movie should be next sequel is
senior year like they're so excited but
they have to apply to college like are
they gonna stay together are they gonna
go and that's cute but it's a strain on
their relationship like the best parts
of the movie are on
together like I don't what I don't mean
it that's why I like sequels like High
School Musical to like trying Gabriella
at the Country Club like that wasn't fun
to watch no and honestly like we can't
even go into it but High School Musical
is deeply problematic because Joe's his
first shar-pei exact honestly justice
for her brother he was such a
hard-working receive justice like all
the time cuz he he was with Kelsie and
things on both sides everyone like saw
the good in him but no one saw like the
humanity in Sharpay right it's like it's
like harmony because everyone like
thinks that fifth harmony sucks that
Camille has the best but like honestly
like I pissed if I was in fifth harmony
like kamila just ditched us and we had
this whole thing like going on we had a
good thing going that's a shar-pei like
everything was fine like no one else
wanted to be involved in the theater
they called her a loser and she took all
that because she had a love for her
craft right and she worked hard at it
and like she prioritized it over
everything whereas like Gabriella was
prioritizing science and Troy was
prioritizing basketball and if you want
to be the lead in the musical like this
needs to be your priority I couldn't
have any more today and also like when
she was helping Troy in the Country Club
like she was trying to help him like and
everyone thought she was being sluicey
like and also like she's not yes she's
not like sleuthy trying to steal Troy
like she likes him like it's a crush
what about her you know when we got
reales feelings no it's just like now I
see it as an adult and I'm like really
sucks nobody's like chef Hayes is human
just like the rest of us you guys and
she just wants towels imported from
Turkey and lobster important from me
that is the best song I'm gonna relax
and renew you must do but over there but
she didn't get her own spin off shar
peis fabulous adventure did she yes she
didn't wait so how does that song go the
lyrics in the beginning I want it all no
no but I want an hour it's like iced tea
imported from England towel yeah that is
just a brilliant song thanks Kimmy or
take us finest work
no oh if you saw the sentence it's his
finest work yeah you haven't given it a
chance how can you say that I just don't
want to it's so good and Jeff Cameron is
the most beautiful girl in the entire
that should be a Carson I know it loves
Sophia Carson yeah to look like she's
our friend
right so how are you do you not support
your friends not all did you not see
what other women Wow
Wow that's JIP ever
I don't applies to everything it's so
crazy like it's like she is being an
actress she's insane Marga what are the
lyrics out with the old and in with the
new goodbye pods of gray
hello skies of blue i dip in the pool a
trip to the spa and the stays in my
shades the whole world according to AA
Dean excuse me Dean he played the wrong
note and then how does it go
iced tea imported from England Life
Guards imported from Spain Charles
imported from Turkey and Turkey imported
from a Iain got it thank you my god that
was important yeah also the reason i
were really dilly dallying this morning
was because there was absolutely no news
and I have no I feel no rush to I would
say that we've been rushed like every
show for the past month like what's just
wrong right and there's really if we
never went into the past five today you
guys would be fine we will we pulled
teeth for you but there's just no rush
on it now let's talk about our toaster
movie of the week we gave you like so
much time because now it's been like
three weeks so if you didn't have time
to watch it it's not my problem
where did you watch it where was it
available um it was available on Netflix
but with the new Apple TV I just
searched in the search preppie
connection it shows you everywhere it's
available so it was available a lot yeah
it's important it's important to have
movies that are available for free for
people because little children like we
all had to buy and it was not worth in
my life like Kate Winslet is just lining
her pockets and like you know it's it's
hard out here for a toaster okay so
what's it what did you think okay I mean
it was a such a great interesting film
very dark like interesting story love a
good true story and I very much enjoyed
it and it was like I was saying this
tomorrow and I feel like such a film
critic saying this but there was
something just so like anti-climactic
about in just like linear like story
peak arrested but then there was like no
no end really like it was just like all
along that we knew he was coming down
because like he's on the walking
escalator with Lucy fry from Vampire
Academy which is also an amazing film
and she's a great actress and she's
gorgeous the only other thing I saw her
in his Vampire Academy where she's a
vampire and it's like her mouth is so
vampire II and then like
here she's a prep student and she still
looks like a vampire like honestly the
movie was pitiful because the two
protagonists like just kept making bad
decisions and like being stupid and I
was like it was I knew what was coming
and it's like you're just waiting for
like the diary at a common do you know
what I mean right at but the reason why
I didn't have a huge penis because he
didn't have a pit he was like I'm not
scared of anything like he didn't really
care so that made me like not really
care except when she was just like a
[ __ ] like yeah are you doing like
totally yeah totally and like when they
were in Colombia like running like I
can't write we're like in that like Club
yeah like the whole thing it was and
like they wanted to kidnap her and they
they killed their friend over it like my
way no playing around and why did he
have to steal that guy's cocaine like so
stupid so she but only to flush it down
the toilet but then to not right and
like that guy Ellis like Abby I hate him
so much I have to tell you something
like drugs like you can get drugs in
America like what what the holidays in
the eighties I think it's like wolf of
Wall Street where like you know how much
they're doing cooking like it was like a
new thing okay that's true and also like
if you get trapped like I even if this
was in 2018 like he would be getting
drugs in America from a drug dealer the
drug dealers making the money like he
was making like he was the drug dealer
right cuz he was like [ __ ] gonna put
himself through college honestly like
the movie was the epitome of loser like
this did all he wanted was like to be in
with the cool kids and like he literally
ruined his life just to be cool right
kids were such losers okay they are evil
I was reading an article like the real
story and that he was found with
$300,000 worth of cocaine Wow
he went down that he collected $300,000
from those idiots idiots like just so
crazy good movie like that you probably
never would have seen I just loved an
interesting story and I didn't know the
backstory so like it was really like
what's gonna happen like what he went to
Columbia I was like I didn't know
anything about the movie I thought it
was like school ties like just a prep
school movie you know like I'm like how
what is this movie right and then it
just didn't turn out to be what I
thought it was gonna be and I just wish
he had like rationed it better because
like those kids like they were really
just doing it way too much like if
everyone's doing it like in hotel rooms
everyone and they were doing so much I
went that guy through a TV out there
would know like and they were all so
[ __ ] up that girl killing herself like
that broke my heart no but they were
like if only they were like a little bit
smarter as you wouldn't
to keep going back you know ya know like
they did in a night what like most most
people would do and I guess like a month
so like if he just like rationed it
better totally wouldn't like he would
have had this going for a really long
time he's gonna mean a lot of money and
then like stock the key and this is with
all these movies where I'm like wolf of
Wall Street ooh it's like you have to
know when it's over learn enough about
Jordan Belfort just had resigned and you
know and Coach Taylor would have stopped
looking into him at the SEC like he
would have gotten away with all of it
when you get to its the Harvey Weinstein
and when you get to a certain level you
just can't stop and it's like knowing
when to stop is so important even like
Bernie Madoff in some of these movies
it's like there was a point where he
could have just stopped and he would
have gotten away with it I'm honestly
glad he didn't but it's just get too
greedy so soon and that greed is fine
and it makes the world go round but you
just have to know when it's like okay I
have what I need you ever see the show
on MSNBC the greatest network of all
time American greed I've seen the
commercials it's like hour-long episode
documentary like e true Hollywood story
vibes I like some of the greatest scams
in American history and it's [ __ ]
wild like what people will do just for
money like John LaVon
there was this guy that the next host
movie of the week yes okay officially
actually because like I don't know
because let me shoot when we watch like
with the baby thug because we hyped it
up way too much for that and then they
were like feeding off each other saying
that it was shitty yeah they were being
annoyed they were anyway and if it
wasn't a true story it wouldn't be so
interesting I think it's honestly one of
the best movies and most underrated
movies ever I just love these nice
little true stories that it's like wow
this really happened in luckily so the
next movie it's a Netflix movie so it's
free yeah it's a Netflix original
starring Jack Black it's called the
sweet it's Jack Black's
finest works in School of Rock it's
called the Polka King
vol ka and when I don't know who told me
to watch it first I think it was our
friend Danny well she was like she kept
saying the Polka King I thought she was
saying the poker so thought it was an
idea about gambling yeah but it was it
was not it was definitely it was so
different beginning you're gonna be like
what am i watching yeah and just give it
30 minutes and try not to [ __ ] throw
a knife at the TV it when his wife comes
on because she isn't the [ __ ] worst
but she's also the girl that was dating
Chris
in real life yeah Captain America yeah
what yes we are saying but she is like a
real actress yeah no you guys are gonna
end the just watch the movie we will
discuss it next week after Labor Day
Jack Black is like physically a
recognizable also what was good about
this movie
preppy connection is the guy who Tobey
he's also from Project X so like his
characters already believable as like
sort of a you know a like bad behavior
like getting into trouble don't give a
[ __ ] yeah like he's a bad boy image
right so like I was believing him I was
believing her she was like totally Palm
Beach she was so like oh no she was just
a dumb like classic dumb [ __ ] you know
yeah for sure and then that guy Ellis
like he was a great actor he was which
one Ellis the one who called the feds oh
yeah
he was the third yeah like was his
middle part and his hair behind his ear
is totally here's okay so now that we've
officially wasted 30 minutes Chris Evans
is Captain America is he not
I might have at it I get the Chris
Christie's Hines great high right so she
from polka King was dating Chris Pines
Captain America
blondie the one from from what's your
number do you want to hear one of the
most interesting facts about Chris from
what's your number I don't know his last
name it's not pine and it's Chris Pine
is no Chris Pine is from that movie with
Reese Witherspoon where the two guys
This Means War
he's brunette and like dark eyebrows
wait hold on we have to get to the
bottom of this yeah Chris Evans is
Captain America no Chris Pine is this
handsome man no no but he's on Captain
America he's not no Chris Evans go to
Chris Evans from oh my god they're so
similar there's so someone that's
Captain America and you want to be so
interesting that Evans which one of them
was dating Jenny who's Jenny costly
Jenny slate jiseop Olga Kings wife oh
you're right I'm pretty sure it's Chris
Jenny slate Chris Chris plan include
Evans like are the same person
this is why people think like it's Evans
it is Chris Evan Chris Evans
and Chris Evans is Captain America so
Captain America what's your number god
Chris Pine is Captain America
no it's evidences Captain America but a
Chris Pine in this story is nothing
Chris Pine there's been Wonder Woman hey
ya know what's your number Captain
America Jenny slate by the way I just
want to say I got it right the first
time and someone in the comments [ __ ]
me up okay well here's the most
interesting fact about Chris Evans yes
for a brief moment do you know who he
was dating Jenny slate
yes but Aspen from season two of
Vanderpump rules that blonde girl with a
little football about Phillip they hated
for like a minute but your name is Vail
oh my god I got my a few locations
I got my ski lodge and so I wait now
that I think about it I think that's
Chris Pine who David Aspen oh that is so
funny
oh my anyways you'll figure it all out
for yourselves are you ready so here's
what's gonna go down we will finally do
the Fast Five then we will do tear
toasters my grabby poles yes okay she
email them to me and then what else do
we that was it okay so without further
ado here are the Fast Five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
okay first up Kylie Jenner joins Kendall
and Kanye as an adidas ambassador this
is a big deal Kylie shared yesterday
she's so excited to announce that she's
officially a hashtag adidas ambassador
hashtag created with Adidas but why did
he dissing her she was MoMA
they must have bought her out of her
contract which is a major and Selena's
Puma now right she they paid they're
paying her three and a half million
dollars per Instagram post I don't think
it's working I don't think it's working
and like I guess she's the most fellow
person
on Instagram I just can't explain how
bizarre I think that is look I can't
believe that Taylor Swift or Kim Kim or
like Cristiano Ronaldo
like I can't believe there isn't someone
with more Instagram followers than
Selena Gomez besides Instagram right
well I do also want to say Instagram
having the most integral hours is weird
because they're inserted [ __ ] sucks no
but it's like when you join Instagram
they could all the other yes like anyone
who like isn't in tune right so it's a
bunch of stuff I miss if I'd literally I
don't think I've actually ever followed
their Instagram but it absolutely
they just take all this to tolerated
like sucks I mean whatever
I can't believe Kylie cross to the other
side wait I caught up on Kardashians I
kept up with the Kardashians okay wait
we'll talk about it in a second I just
want to say the thing about puma is like
they really don't need anyone other than
Rihanna like what she's doing for the
brand is like so about a camera anymore
instead of paying Selena Gomez or like
even contracting Kylie back like a few
years ago like just up Rihanna's
contract she's technically that's
creative director and like I don't think
she shows up for work every day but what
she's doing like is like game change so
relevant
every day you're selling Puma at the
second floor of Bloomingdale's and I am
buying it but so her brand fenty is Puma
yes it's like what about the beauty - no
Fendi beauty is not okay but like but I
was like ven TX Puma like a collab once
no are you sure I'm pretty sure but then
she also does other clubs like I saw I
keep getting like served Facebook ads
for like savage Fendi which is like her
lingerie collection I don't think that
has anything to do with Puma
but she is Puma interesting whom is such
a weird brand because like they weren't
around when we were kids and they were
like those ugly sneakers but we wore
them yeah my friend only to always wear
Pumas and I remember one like Puma like
hired Rihanna I was like there's no way
Pumas ever gonna be cool and like now
here we are like it's not adidas but
like it's not Reebok what do you think
it's not New Balance it's not a balance
I like New Balance you're like nerdy and
cool there so dad um there my dementia
is getting so bad I also it's cuz you
drank last night that makes it worse
does when I drink a night before I can't
put my thoughts together I can't speak
what were we talking about five seconds
ago
uh-oh when you dig up in what do you
think of Rossi like I move on okay so
funny I almost like you almost didn't
know I did and I was like there's no way
that's what you are of course and if you
don't know that reference should she
offer you bro she's too young for you
bro but uh world so true nowadays kylie
is now officially part of the adidas
family and like I feel really good about
it I feel like this has come full circle
because I remember when she would there
were rumors she was signing with Puma
Kanye tweeted like there's no way
Kylie's going to Puma and then she did
so adidas definitely like is paying her
the big bucks which she deserves also I
just feel like Kanye like getting Chi
to be in with adidas like only helps
cement his relationship with Adidas
because from what I see like publicly is
that like a ton of adidas his revenue
comes from Kanye like he's their most
valuable asset but and he says otherwise
and he says that they're really unhappy
with Kanye and that like the company's
in debt so if that's true
Conny bringing kylie along is just great
like it really gives him like five more
years
definitely and if they bought kylie out
of her puma contract and she signed a
new one like this might have just pushed
her over the billion line which we've
all been we've all been crowdsource
crowdfunding for her totally how much do
you think her contracts or thanks do you
think she uses like a fancy one we've
never heard of like Swiss bank I would
yeah no but they decorated Suisse credit
Chris yeah credit no credit Swedes with
a K start their own bank they probably
do like I'm just like at a certain level
like there's a bank for you know but
like okay let's say Kylie needs cash
like what she does like she probably
carries at all times like a thousand
dollars and just in her wallet like ten
hundreds where does she go to get it not
an ATM maybe she's one of those brink
trucks come drive up to her house yeah
and put it in the vault perhaps I never
thought about it there's just so many
things when you like reach a level of
like of wealth no wealth that like you
just like don't do do you know any mean
yeah like I don't think right like and
you can you do grocery shop like that's
not crazy but like just like little
logistical things about your life are
just completely different yeah you like
a business manager right that was like
in girlboss when Sophia Amoruso was like
doing Nasty Gal for a while and she was
getting really big and she was like I
had a million dollars in my face college
saving chase College checking account
I heard Sophia Amoruso speak ones and I
just thought she was like so inspiring
and I just feel like her fall from grace
and I'm sorry that's what it is it's
like so disappointing it is and I don't
understand how it happened because like
me yeah a gal never was not in demand
like when they said nasty ah what makeup
it was just me no it was still so cool
and we were still shopping there ya know
it's like wouldn't keep up with the
level of demand but I don't understand
how that's possible if people are buying
her stuff how do you go bankrupt yeah
and like you know it just the whole
thing doesn't really make sense because
now so you got I was like
first of a million like ASOS like they
were way before they were in high school
like everyone like anytime you had an
event like it was a dress so now - yeah
like in college like formal nasty ow it
was like the biggest company in the
world and they were the first like
online fashion retailer but had a
million followers on Instagram like to
this day they have like 1.3 like Vega 2
million years ago I I see I don't know
what happens now if you go in a CIO comm
if you can be I still open something
happened she's not involved anymore
someone picked it back up and like it is
running it again but I just don't
understand what happened and like for
such a like a businesswoman entrepreneur
to get to that level and just like it
dies I don't understand I don't
understand how that happens I'll say I
remember like NASA gal came up with we
were in high school in college like
using our parents credit cards like all
of us like we're scared to shop there
because the name was so salacious it
sounded like like we're shopping for
porn totally totally it was just like so
innovative and so amazing and it was
really like groundbreaking in the
fashion industry and I don't understand
what happened me neither and she'll
never win any another injustice is that
her the Showgirl boss which is based off
of her book didn't get a second season
at Netflix and it was so good okay I
don't think was good but I think her
getting a show was weird as hell like it
was weird but like I watched the show
with resin and it was so good Robertson
it's like one of my favorite material to
watch on on anything and she did such a
good job and I don't know like
everything on that like Netflix just
throws money like in the toilet flushes
it down yes way like why couldn't we get
a second season of girlboss totally I
just and also the end of the first
season is finally when she like has the
name she has the sight it's like all
about to pop off look it's like a cute
way to end it but like the irony of like
it being bankrupt now it's like not lost
on me
right I just I'm like I'm like
disappointed and Sophia Amoruso you know
like her personally she does really well
well yeah she's girl boy is from Nasty
Gal toward the bankruptcy but she had
sold some of it yes she right she sold
like a decent portion of it for 99
million dollars
years ago so I think she's fine I'm
saying LCL is a brave living in San
Francisco and a walk-up having like a
hernia from stress like 99 ml like
she'll be okay yeah agreed okay
are you ready to move on no what were
you talking about we were talking about
Kylie oh I caught up on Kardashians and
I just have to say like Kendall it's
almost worse than Kourtney they did make
a good point about Caitlyn being invited
agree because Courtney was being so
unreasonable like she's all about family
memories family memories so you're not
gonna like kid the kids be with their
dad who like is there all in great terms
with Scott and like that was Courtney's
doing when they got divorced or when
they broke up like he could have been
gone but if she kept him included now
they're all really close to them and
like you can't just decide because you
have a new boyfriend that he don't want
you don't want him to come it's so
obvious that everything Courtney says
and does is what unis really wants
because now we know he's like psycho and
controlling and like why machines like
the girls knew that at the time but they
were being nice by not saying yep also
the difference between Scott and Caitlin
is that Scott is definitely like [ __ ]
up like you know isn't always the best
behaved but he never goes after the
family like he like he just he just
hurts himself lately especially publicly
Caitlyn has gone on like a rainbow tour
taking the Kardashian Kris down and like
it's Christmas Christmas party it's
Christmas party that meant that's the
only difference is that she doesn't have
to invite who she doesn't want but
Kourtney's just like a walking hypocrite
like her the memories the memories with
the family to family and then she breaks
all the traditions almost like gonna
take the kids away for Christmas like so
stupid right like if Caitlin came to the
party she would have like and then I hit
up inviting Caitlyn they should have
like more on a mic and like sold the
footage of course or like where she's
taking pictures Kylie she would have
wrote at Ella
Kylie will didn't like any of the
pictures kylie is like not on the show
it's insane
no and it makes me so sad but I just and
like this is how she wants it so for
that I'm just happy she's getting what
she wants but like I love her so much
even when her and Kim are being stupid
and preying on us which wasn't funny I
was laughing with them me too I was so
happy to be a part of it I just like but
why does Kylie even go to those those
filming sessions where they have to do
like side interviews because she's not
on the show I wonder if she'll be in
next season because he or she's like
pregnant yes yes yes um the side story
of
Kris thinking she's being poisoned is so
funny because I really thought she was
gonna end up being poisoned when that
guy's walking through her house and
she's like who is this guy it's weird
that they had so many people that's what
I said tomorrow I'm like I can't believe
that there's the volume of people that
you don't even know who's in your house
at what point but that's dangerous yeah
but I think they also have people in
their house who keep eyes on the people
in their house there's several people in
the house and when they go to the front
of Krista's house with Jeff Latham
Kourtney and khloé I'm
Khloe and Kim you never get to see that
part of Chris's house and it's gorgeous
yeah it's the driveway with all the palm
trees and loved it
and I don't know Jeff Lee thumb was like
a living for the cameras no totally and
I was just singing about Colton exactly
I was thinking the same thing but the
scene where Kendall's fighting the
stranger things not to Drake ups having
a cup of tea it's not even that Kendall
looks like a completely different person
I had no idea who that was
she like she looks different all the
time because she gets filler in her face
and what about it like I love well I
have a few things to say first of all
like I love people do your work highly
like literally change your whole life
with plastic surgery but Kendall acts
like she's like the natural sister and
she's really really not like she looks a
recognizable these days I'm like right
now I think at this point in time like
she has more on her face and Kylie does
I think so too and there was a point
when Kendall was becoming a model she
got her nose done that was only thing
she got done and she was the natural
you'd be like she was really like maybe
a year before she was in the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show maybe two years
actually like there was like a year
period where she was what she wanted to
pretend to be but she got so skinny
because she does so much run right and
when you get so skinny your face gets
skinny and like you could see your bones
through your face and like that's not
what a model is supposed to look like a
models supposed to somehow have like a
red beautiful plush face and bones for
skin so she definitely gets her face
filled because she doesn't want to look
like that and you can always tell when
she's just gotten it done she always
gets it done right before her interviews
she looks like so so when she's sitting
in that restaurant with Courtney like I
think she's literally just came from the
doctor like she's really puppy and then
like maybe a couple months later she
looks way more normal and way better but
she's got to figure that out and just
like be honest also remember like the
girls like in specifically like their
faces don't move an eyebrow never moves
remember what came like did an episode
where she pretends to where she gets
Botox she's like it really didn't like
reaction like you would you say you're
so honest you had your ass x-rayed on
Tyra and you're still gonna pretend like
you had an allergic reaction to Botox
and you don't get it like total your
face does not move no I mean Chloe I got
Botox once three months ago I make faces
already like is it like yeah I'm a
little a little bit I'll probably get it
in a few like three more months yeah but
like her face that's a cheek
move a mouth doesn't move afar head
doesn't move and like you need to just
tell us really that is so crazy to me so
I never forget about that how Kimber
attends like she's allergic to Botox
totally that is [ __ ] hilarious
allergic to it it makes her face ominous
when she was dualist when she was in
that house where that the one that they
tp'ed and she got psoriasis in that
bathroom remember that it was my
favorite house of hers was that where
Kris Humphries proposed to her yes and
that's also where she lived while she
was pregnant with North for a brief
moment but she didn't wanna live
obviously in the Kris house and she was
richer than but like that house he's my
favorite like the way that they design
their houses now I was like so
minimalist it's like at the Kanye effect
there's like no furniture Kim's house
now yeah Chloe's he's like wait yeah
that scene where her and Kim and Chloe
are sitting on those too late like big
chairs in front of a fireplace and then
you see like later when Kim comes over
to Chloe's house and gets her out of bed
those two chairs and that fireplace are
in Chloe's room that is like my dream
setup like should these two huge amazing
brewery chairs in front of this fire was
and then right behind her is her bed I
was like I need that room yeah I feel
like actually at this point Chloe's
house is like my favorite ooh
Kourtney is too black and white yep and
her kitchen is brown it's so weird yeah
it is weird I noticed the kitchen in
this episode of current her and Chloe's
kitchens like look exactly the same
except they're different colors and
there's so many times they're sitting
around Chloe's kitchen and I think it's
Kourtney's but like Kourtney does
everybody have a round table in front of
a window and like Kim kicked her out yo
how can it be Kourtney's no and that
room where they had that fight in the
glamour was in a movie theater and with
all the snacks oh that must have been
like this after the glam room fight they
go in and had that they had that
conversation where Kourtney's I'm
zooming in our picture that room I
believe it was a movie theater I had
like no windows in there was candy
everywhere I'm like big furry bling it's
like that's my dream I think Club is
house is my favorite because it's like
the most realistic also Chris's house is
amazing
of course and then yeah Kim and Kanye's
houses a little too yeah MLS but we know
they don't film that we already know
about it cuz of charlemagne right oh
that's true because those pictures that
Kanye tweeted out what does he sell this
place yeah and like that room off of
Chris's kitchen with like all the snacks
in the bar that's my favorite room yeah
it just remember their ranch they need
to buy it I can't believe if they don't
own that house number Kim's condo of
course member the townhouse Kourtney and
khloé lived in yeah oh my god this the
condo I just I love all the versions of
that I was like Kim wasn't
successful ones so she had brento wait
do you remember um that blue house that
Kourtney and Scott lived in with like
one or two kids yeah it was like super
cute it really looks like a house in the
suburbs
yeah it's also lived in one that looks
like a cottage a little bit it's that
way yours maybe I think that blue is
like very light blue almost like white
yeah I think we're talking about this is
hang on but it's like those weren't
there how those aren't their houses
no oh and you the ones that they ship
they never show Chloe's house on the
outside today at this point no but I
think in the earlier seasons like they
actually were here Khloe and Lamar's
house was like so cute and so la and
Jessica Simpson and Nick Lachey used to
live there yeah that's an iconic yeah
and I kind of have it's just like it's
so funny to like watch the real estate
develop within the Kardashian like and
now Kendall's house is done in real life
on the show they're like making it seem
like that's her storyline her project
and I saw some footage she has
restoration I read couches they all do
they all do yeah they invented
Restoration Hardware what I've heard
them talking about Restoration Hardware
on their show like Kylie's house is all
Restoration Hardware I expected more
from her I know and they all love those
Toto toilets okay so I think they get
them for free its 1116 are you ready for
the second story of the day oh my god we
got to keep it moving maybe we'll push
tear toasters Taylor Swift stands to
make a music business history as a free
agent oh my god I can't stop talking
about that come November the superstar
will be able to sign a new deal for the
first time since she was 15 and it's
sure to be a big one
this is a variety article yes top so
well-written and really helpful talk
about your blank spaces Taylor Swift is
about to have one in the spot where her
label affiliation goes in less than
three months time she'll be a free agent
as the first anniversary of the release
of her sixth album reputation marks the
official expiration of her obligation to
Big Machine Records and its founder CEO
Scott Borchetta
who signed Swift when she first came to
him as a country pop teenybopper of 15
now 28 and among the most successful
female artists in modern history not to
mention a savvy businesswoman in her own
right Swift has already been free to
negotiate with rival companies though
she couldn't sign a new deal before
November her reps are known to have
preliminary discussions with the major
label groups along with talks about
returning to Big Machine the
nashville-based Universal Music Group
distributed indeed that became a
powerhouse with Swift as its flagship
artist she could hardly be in a better
position to attract suitors she sells
albums so but it's article this article
so good and they go it's like really
long
boring but they go like here's every
route she could take and what it would
mean for the music business but what
they fail to include which i think is
such an important statistic is I believe
and don't quote me on this that her
parents owned a stake in big machine
because Scott Borchetta who is like he
is like 113,000 Instagram followers like
all the Swifty's know him and he's the
guy in hurry true Hollywood story and I
knew he looked familiar and that's why
he was like just starting out and was
gonna like make his bones to Taylor
Swift and I believed that Scott and
whatever Andrea gave him money to start
the label and so they definitely own a
part of it and then I think it was sold
to Universal Music Group so they might
not be sick shareholders anymore but he
got paid out right but I do think that
they're invested somehow and so anytime
the label makes money they make money so
her moving like wouldn't really make
sense from that perspective but that's
not like public information so people
don't know like if they really are
involved or not I don't know yeah you
don't Wikipedia so they up Swift's
father owns a stake in the record label
say how much no thank you I feel like
that's great for them like to have a
piece of business but I don't think
that'll influence her decision first of
all I feel like she I could see her like
not joining another record label cuz she
really doesn't need to like if
somebody's article says a business in
herself exactly and what this article
says is that the last maybe two or three
albums but then when you get to a level
of making the most money like Garth
Brooks money it's you own your music and
right now fearless the Taylor Swift
original album and I believe Speak Now
are owns like the actual content is
owned by the record label and in order
to to really let get to that next level
you own your own music so part of her
what they said part of her negotiations
are her owning all of her music and
probably buying out big machine like
from literally owning her content the
big machine makes up 80% of their yearly
profits that's like a projection from
Taylor Swift so this could put them out
of business yeah but now she also
established them like I think she's
ready to move on I don't doesn't even
matter I don't see her like moving to a
bigger leap like she doesn't need
anything you know what this really like
reminds me of them really brings true
remember in that Kanye interview with
Charlemagne where he's talking about how
he fired Scooter Braun not because
scooter did anything like he loves
scooter but because scooter like taught
him that like
he needs to be this like artists need to
artist our businesses and instead of
having like a manager and an agent
artists need CEOs like they are
businesses like that's how I feel like
Taylor is gonna structure no she's so
[ __ ] smart and hurt her family her
dad is like a wealth manager so like
she's always been like money money money
and people are like well they could
wherever she goes could influence her
creative artistic like no Taylor Swift
can't be told what to do like no matter
where she goes she's in charge and it's
it's not gonna affect her what so she
has her own studios like she has she was
Wonder House creatively this means
nothing for Taylor Swift yeah her next
album is still gonna be what she wants
it to be whoever records it you know but
yes this is now about taking it to level
of owning it why would she surprised if
she started another Swift LLC yeah and
she's just gonna like business herself
and she should sign artists she believes
in yeah
like jay-z Rob nation yeah that's a
record label yeah and she's always like
supporting like Kelsea Ballerini aha
girl that's friends with Becca Tilly
that she brought on seating with Yoko
and she really elevates like people to a
next level just like by including them
so she took that song take your time by
Sam Hawn and like she made it next level
just by performing it at one of her
shows like she should start her own
label 100% and sign like a Carly Pierce
someone she believes in you know Nemean
yeah but also it's like does she like
she's an artist as she but she actually
does she welcomed partition and no not
even that like does she want to be on
the business side of yes as much as on
the artistry side but she doesn't want
to be on the business she wants to get
that at the top of the business it's
like she's not gonna run her own record
label you know no but I guess she would
like hire someone and then just collect
all the funds highway 65 Nashville style
exactly exactly she is like she's so
smart I'm so excited to see what she
does because whatever it is it's gonna
be a unique original idea that no one's
done before and people will probably
make fun of her for it and then in five
years she'll end up literally probably
like tripling her net worth right and
it's just one decision regardless of
what path she chooses either she's like
just sides with Warner Brothers or
something she will be making music
history right that's pretty and this is
so exciting this doesn't happen all the
time yeah it's I feel like this is like
what sports people like when people are
free Asian this is how the queers LeBron
I'm gonna go that's how we feel that
Taylor Swift
every time someone tells me she's 28 I
like freak out because the song 22 which
came out when she was 22 like feels like
just like three years ago it was
I was in college meet you so and I'm
coming up at my five year reunion um wow
that old thing we all go back to Colgate
for a Colgate weekend it was in 2012 and
I was 2018 six years yeah that's perfect
math because I was a freshman in college
and also like the song probably came out
a year after she was 22 it's just like
her career is and like never ceases to
amaze me
no and I will never stop defending her
seriously except I'm really getting to a
point where I can't defend Kim Zolciak
anymore like you know there are people
who like I love and that even when they
do wrong I'll just like still be there
like their number one fan but she's
making it so hard she tweeted this
morning that complete she's always
tweeting at Delta they trying to blow
them up for like doing in justices and
like this one wasn't even in justice
she's sitting in the last round with
first class and by the time they got to
her they had like ran out of like
certain foods so she didn't get it okay
like look she's she trip to Twitter of
putting up is that possible because
still think allocate I know so it
happened to me too it's like they have
like 16 people and they'll have like two
options so they'll have like 10 in the
chicken and six of the steak but then
like everyone orders one yeah they never
know which one's gonna be more popular
yes point they should know at this point
this is just have 16 of each right
aren't they frozen foods can't she just
save them for the next fight total it
does seem like an oversight know what is
annoying but like her blowing it up
being like like act like what you want
people abuse they're so Kelly Cutrone
like people who abuse their social
following not to like
name a brand when they've done something
wrong great but when it's like not a big
deal relax yeah but it's like Kelly
Cutrone was like really taking up like a
police time where like if Kim wants to
tweet into the void yeah okay look that
pissed me off and like and now I'm like
annoyed with her okay but like I feel
like we just need to go be tardy it's
taking a long time I feel like there's a
lot of time between don't be tardy
seasons always I'm always like it's that
show coming back I feel like that yeah I
guess it's a year yeah well it's 11:23
are you ready for the third story gotta
breathe okay this is a breezy one
because it's a story about an Instagram
comment wait I am like not watching the
comments today because you told me if so
I was like watching too much and I agree
it's like it's distracting but I feel
like we're not live and nobody's
watching genome even totally it's like
we're not record we forgot to hit record
well it's here and I can tell you we're
live
what are people saying I'm not looking
because it's distracting good and
because we are in a time crunch I was so
itchy you could talk Wow oh yeah oh my
god [ __ ] eat oh oh okay anyways this
next story is just a story about an
Instagram comment sober tip okay so your
blog I seen a twist went from breath
dragons in at least katharine mcphee
trolls her future stepdaughter Erin
Foster while on vacation with quote
daddy David Foster wings growth they
also spell out the ages katharine McPhee
34 trolls her future stepdaughter Erin
foster 36 while on vacation with Daddy
Devon David Foster 68 uh so basically
katharine mcphee posted like a pretty
photo of herself and erin foster
commented feels like i could have been
invited on this beautiful trip and
katharine mcphee replied mommy and daddy
need alone time she is there to flake
that is so not nothing but like I feel
like they're all getting along
yeah and I think that Erin & Sarah
actually like Katherine and I feel like
they really just want to have it to be
happy like they're old enough that it's
like big care anymore I know this is his
how many number engagements like I don't
think they expect him to change anytime
soon and a piece happy when he was
married to Yolande I like those were the
good old days and they had that house oh
that house does she still live there no
she has a condo because and she wouldn't
know she moved to New York it's a sell
it for limes equipment right and now she
moved to New York to be closer to her
girl she lives downtown Oh does she
yeah I know where she lives do you gonna
say that's like when scheana told where
lollol is I'm watching I'm like totally
okay we're friends and I don't know you
Lana but it was a friend
now you know no I'm happy for Katherine
Katherine McPhee did something so funny
on Twitter yesterday she's really trying
to encourage people to vote in their
like local primary elections cuz it's
really important which it is everyone
should register um and she did a tweet
like voting matters and then she put up
a picture of her and Taylor Hicks
because if you remember katharine McPhee
came in second on American Idol to
Taylor Hicks who went nowhere and had
gray hair at the age of 25 I think if I
ran American Idol I actually wouldn't
want to win it's like but it's a Kurt a
sucker-like is the daughter Kelly
Clarkson Carrie Underwood what's up with
Ruben Studdard just even in Syria Margo
please look it up I'm on it
I love him he was so supremely - and
then wasn't there that what Eva it was
in Chiana no I don't know but a show
yeah take a breather she didn't I'm
sorry
Eva's from America's Next Top Model and
she's on Real Housewives of Atlanta yes
does Eve I think I don't know Eva I
don't know if I so bad who were just
talking about uh I think the Fantasia
Barrino might have won she did oh so
yeah but she's not cursed where's she at
oh my god she's like vegan Broadway
Broadway Broadway hey $8 no she's on
bribes is it color purple Aretha
Franklin said she wanted Fantasia to
play her in her biopic well I was like
one of the most well respected artists
of our time you know what that's a great
segue to our fourth story and 11:27 75
thousand followers called real Ruben
Studdard can you give me your phone yeah
is there a fake Ruben Studdard that's a
great segue for our fourth story at
11:26 which is that ariana grande is
performing at Aretha Franklin's funeral
oh that's beautiful yeah ariana grande
will be among the performers who will
pay tribute to a wreath of rain Qin at
her funeral Friday grande will be among
entertainers Stevie Wonder Jennifer
Hudson Fantasia
I told you Faith Hill are you gonna go
snitch surely she can remember the word
Shirley Caesar Chaka Khan and more
Franklin's rep Gwendolyn Quinn says
Franklin met Grande when the two
performed at the White House in 2014 for
then President Barack Obama and first
lady Michelle Obama as part of the quote
women of soul concert hold on it's
really important for everyone to know
that Ruben Studdard lost a decent amount
of weight and he looks hot look he looks
good and they follow him out and what
does he do for a living
he definitely like sings here and there
like I feel like he has a nice life yeah
cuz he's so actually he is so
recognizable actually I know like if I
lived me or him like I would hire him
till he come sing at my wedding of
course
he would do an amazing job amazing voice
so was this sweet this actual funeral or
it's a or is it like a televised right
cuz it's always so weird how like for
mostly funerals that I go to or jewish
funerals and you have to bury the person
the day after they die like no matter
the circumstance I feel like I was
reading stuff about her like open casket
and her fans were coming to like say
their goodbyes what maybe I had a dream
about it out me yeah it's really crazy
his body is just on display for two full
days and fans can come in and we're like
wherever she lives there's pictures in
Daily Mail like I didn't see her in
Daily Mail you see her sorry they don't
show the face but you see like she's in
a red getup and my gosh
it's crazy I wonder if Kim and Mario did
her makeup totally well so here's what
I'm saying is like when you're um when
you go to a Jewish funeral it has to be
the day after the person died like no
matter the circumstance like you really
can't wait more than a day and even if
it's like at night like it's crazy so if
it's if you see the body which I think
only the family does it's like fresh if
you wait she died what like two weeks
ago
yeah but they they put that stuff in you
it's so crazy it's crazy but that's how
most I mean jeez are the minority so
that's how most people do it I don't
think I've ever been to an Andres
funeral actually that's definitely not
true yeah I think they have to laugh and
cinnamon um so Ariana Grande will be
amongst the many performers I wonder if
it's gonna be televised it's so weird
honestly the only funeral I was ever
interested in going to was Joan Rivers
because it sounded like the most lit
thing ever and like that it was the
funniest thing ever
yeah damn alright hey I wonder if they
recorded it just like weirdly like just
for personal I don't think it's that
weird I think it's weird it is weird
yeah it was a temple Emmanuel like the
biggest most beautiful jewel I miss her
literally does not get easier it does
not get easier and literally every time
I remember that she's gone on like I
have
same reaction of sadness every time I
miss Joan Rivers I are there watch piece
of work documentary there's like not
enough documentaries on her like that
her life was just getting interesting
yeah she actually there's a lot of
content out there about her you can
watch like you can watch it in bed with
Joan and Melissa that's just like random
random Internet content then there that
Joe and we TV
yeah then she's been doing red carpets
for years like I'm sure he can find them
you can watch her on The Apprentice
where she won and she like won back her
whole career her career like if you read
her book like her career was in the
gutter and then so she went on
apprentice and she won and Celebrity
Apprentice Celebrity Apprentice yeah and
the sauce of the season Chloe was on it
and she got kicked off because like she
had to go to court for her D for her DUI
oh my god I have to watch this and Jesse
James to her Gandhi oh my god I have to
watch it's an amazing season and then
Joan wins spoiler but that's what
propelled then she got fashion police
and her career like if you watch piece
of work that's before apprentice oh is
it and then she wins a prime minister
ting piece of work and you see she's
getting all these opportunities it's
like an amazing thing okay I need to
rewatch now with this mindset but what I
was going to say is I watch at TMZ clip
of her outside the airport calling
Selena Gomez dumb and it's my favorite
thing of all time yeah do you do with
Selena Gomez said Selena Gomez that
college grad the best suit clip him ever
the best line of all of all time she was
just epic and honestly with all the
trials tribulations and terrible things
going on in the world today
we never have needed a Joan Rivers more
because you wonder what she was she was
just so rational so rational voice of
reason voice of reason and really like
understood like it's a joke
like we're just trying to make people
laugh like I am still not well I was
reading her book like a year ago and she
and she wrote the book maybe at this
point like 10 years ago or eight years
ago and she had like she was talking
about The Bachelor for one second she
talked about the people that go on oh my
god we needed her and she in one line
she like completely summed it up she had
like absolutely no time for it and
imagine like and that was before
fabfitfun
right imagine where we'd be today I mean
I still follow her on Twitter and I
think the weirdest thing ever is like
maybe three or four times a week
Melissa tweets like a flashback photo of
them and apps herself like to - trying
to get followers I
followed her social media because it was
it's bad yeah what's your approach when
someone passes away do you for unfollow
them it depends who yeah if it's like a
person I know no yeah but if it's like a
celebrity I'll leave it for a little bit
like it's being and then I'll stop it
depends if they never post again I
probably would never unfollow them
do you remember tribe so electric yes of
course that was one of the things I was
thinking of was it because he was like a
meme account but like he was like a
really talented comic he was the
funniest person on instagram that did so
many things that we now say and he like
had just like made it into a meme like
sorry I'm late I didn't want to come
like that was him he being alive is
really [ __ ] time-consuming something
like like these classic things we say he
invented them and his [ __ ] was all over
the internet and he was like really like
blowing up and then literally one day he
was gone yeah nobody ever felt he wasn't
like a big enough celebrity like also in
like a few years ago so like never
really serves it and we never really got
answers and nobody found out what
happened but all of his pages are still
up and you should actually go check them
out so funny so funny but that was so
crazy yeah okay 11:33 faith and final
story crazy rich Asians tops the box
office again with this crazy second
weekend crazier changes is so crazy rich
at the box office weren't the Warner
Brothers rom-com brought in and somebody
waiting their whole life to write that
centre-right brought in an estimated 25
million in the second weekend to once
again topped the box office that's just
a 6% drop for him it's haul over the
previous weekend and nearly unheard at
the box office
most films experience a sizable drop
once the buzz of its opening fades this
is not surprising to me first of all
because this is a anything that's like
based off of his successful book is
already set up for success because
there's a built-in audience of people
who already read the book anything that
comes out during the summer when there
is not one thing to see like I checked
the movies all the time I love going to
movies I will literally see anything
just to sit out I pick and like have
spicy tuna I'm so and I don't haven't
gone in months cuz there's not a thing
to see like so I like I would see
[ __ ] like Justice League to go to the
movies and be an air conditioning
especially in the summer I'm like oh
recliner yep and like but I'm not home
right home somewhere else so like this
isn't surprising I'm just I'm so glad
it's doing well but like everyone was
like wow this is really
history breaking know what's history
breaking is the fact that there is
absolutely nothing to watch these days
you know but the reason why it's so
impressive is because it's an the main
characters our agent American which is
like never has happened because but
people who like actors who are
minorities are always like the funny
friend on the side you know like or like
Aquafina in oceans oceans sorry and she
was like the crate like they're you know
they're always just like like a token
character whereas now like this is just
a month for Asian Americans because we
clean - all the boys that love before
and crazy fridge asians it's like proof
that you can have a successful romantic
comedy you can have a successful
streaming you why a film with asian
american leads and it just sets a
precedent i agree and i excited and i
think there are any setting out for
crazy rich agents to and i think they're
setting up for 12 boys a lot before -
i'm gonna see crazy rich Asians this
weekend - from having a staycation oh
right so it's Labor Day Labor Day yes
I'm that weird what I like paused for
you to chime in you know later but what
is it which one's Labor Day I got them
confused Labor Day is when you can't
wear white after and Josie did know
seriously which what do we what do we
commemorating uh the beginning of Labor
Inc yeah right because I get more yelled
a Labor Day and Arbor Day confused and
Veterans Day and I'm Columbus Day no
actually we know Columbus Day it's not
good it's in Columbus taste like so
controversial I know like it's just so
weird that there's like a day that's
controversial you know I'm like for a
good reason like he killed like a
million people but like for me Columbus
Day it's like it's so not about Columbus
no and it's about us it's about having
his three-day weekend in the middle of
the fall and like I am planning so like
mine's all revolves around Columbus Day
and how I'm using that weekend cuz right
now like I was maybe gonna do my
Bachelorette that weekend homegirl
you have got to tell me these things
right now I I have your schedule in mind
when I'm like I said my way I look at
your website yeah but I haven't planned
anything else we just edit two shows in
the linen Albany girl with no job calm I
saw that I make sure I maybe I plan up
my whole life around holiday weekend so
my Bachelorette like might just be MLK
weekend cuz that's next one okay wait oh
wait no no no why don't do it I already
have a trip planned to Mexico for MLK
yeah my same trip is last year oh okay
fine
see okay easy enough okay um so yeah my
life revolves around holiday weekend
today my
actually just be going to Dallas I have
some big things planned have I told you
about this yeah I think you did so we're
not going to a show on Friday because
I'm off to the Hamptons with the points
guy gallivanting across town I got to
figure out how to get there I really
don't want to drive like by myself for
two hours why don't you black day
because it's really expensive and really
scary and I always like telling people
how dangerous blade is then I'm like
taking it myself you didn't take the
train no I took the train once and it
was one of the worst experiences I'd
rather sit in traffic on the jitney with
air conditioning but the ambassador it's
only 25 dollars more the genies have so
bad no it's really not you never know
you can meet them Jenny
I wouldn't know sign your mother that my
whole way how nice
yeah so no show on Friday Monday's Labor
Day so no show Monday Tuesday I'm moving
to my new apartment that I finally
finally finally got approved for I'm so
excited yeah so you don't know this yet
but we are having a snitch on the tow
situation you start school what are we
gonna do we'll figure it out so you
still want that raise but you might have
to find the codes and you know well I
think I'm missing the first week of
school to go to camp Tosa that's the
only day that I you're forget here's the
thing guys I tried
there's no so no Monday Tuesday
Wednesday we are here right before we
put our scarves around our necks and
head up in our convertible to captain we
got a convertible I'm working on it I
mean yes is that what we want but we
need for people like honesty we should
just get like an SUV or a min again okay
the place that I got a car from rally
motors and Glendale very prestigious I
don't think they have a minivan g-wagen
yeah do you get a Jeep Wrangler done
they don't do Jeep they do we'll pick
out a card pinning I can get one and
they prove it but BMW missive is
lexus acura i think that's it for so we
can't get it
g-wagen yeah do you want it that's mercy
even though I really have a thing
against you again wow those are the cars
of the Nazis used I thought no like the
Nazis themselves drove jobs
yeah because Mercedes is a surly company
those are like their army looking truck
yeah be like an acura yeah like
something American like
cheap beginning Ford what we're gonna
have to go elsewhere okay
it's Lexus an American car yeah I get so
confused I don't know anyways so we will
be back Oh tomorrow and then Wednesday
two cantos neverovsky cam toes by the
way I've gotten like a million questions
about cam shows because people are like
so nervous about buying their ticket
here does go to the event right the
password is in all caps premium I can't
say it enough I get a million do you
have premium all caps right link in bio
on our Instagram or just click to get
tickets on our Instagram um
tickets are 525 that includes all your
food all your liquor for like four days
all your fun all your friends all you
need to do is bring all your toast all
you do is bring like your bedding and
clothes and like makeup if you want I'm
not wearing makeup the whole time
and yeah it's gonna be a good time we'll
post it a packing list in the camp toast
Facebook group um but it's really like
bring whatever you want like whatever
you feel comfortable in I hope it's like
I hope this heat wave and break this but
if it doesn't like we OB it we have two
pools we can go in the lake totally I
love a pool and we have to the zipline
zipline Landon Lake okay well I'm off to
the US Open just to be like the
socialite that I am well that's it and
that's it we will see you back here
tomorrow
I mean we'll do just do deer toasters
tomorrow it's so crazy for a show where
I was literally pulling teeth for
stories we couldn't set dog any remember
when we were not in a rush guys
you